all right we're here Sam no that's not
Sam that's - Wow
no new friend of the hustle uh great to
be in hustle tell the people who is Stu
Stu is a friend of the hustle
I actually met Sam through a mutual
mentor Chris read let's shut up Chris
read let's last mile and transmedia
capital and work out of here I do work
out of here it's incredible man I was
working at a home and so was my partner
and for the people that know me on the
phone about twelve hours a day
most of my things are just brokering
deals and she kicked me out right here I
am Sam took in one of the refugees like
you guys talked about last time that's
me yeah and we after the last episode
you were you were listening in and
normally after every episode we're like
you know how was it to the people that
were kind of in the room and it's
usually like good yeah I liked it and
you were like it was good but here's
three things I think you guys could do
better and I was like nice who is this
guy
no one likes a yes-man yeah no one likes
a yes-man especially if you're trying to
make something great you always wanna
nobody also like to hate her you need an
honest person you know hunter person and
so you were honest I like that and then
we started talking about I don't know
how we start talk about ideas we just
bumped into each other started
immediately jamming on some ideas and I
was like hold on this should have been
recorded come by next week let's do this
and also I am with Sam gone and we gotta
say he's with the garyvee podcast and
you're stuck with me so I don't know
who's with you that well I'm gonna do
that I'm not trying to be on one of
those Instagram posts where it starts
out with his signature on the screen his
autograph
at the start I will say this office now
compared to last week we gotta say Henry
put it in a ton of work this office
looks a thousand times better than Gary
Vee spots out Henry what you have a
Twitter handle
Henry Billings five you know chef
returning the studio's incredible for
everyone that's just listening at home
what the studio used to look like is if
close your eyes and a matte yet to
wealthy guys went on Amazon and they
search by highest price for comfortable
chair and they bought it and right red
chair and they found a broom closet and
put it in there with some of their books
and now it legit looks like a legitimate
studio now studio yeah there's like the
soundproofing [__] on the walls there's
posters behind us looks like a very like
prestigious looking book that just says
Sam remove my glasses
it's like did
like he died if we have a commute here
shouts out to Sam come back save so Sam
did the garyvee podcast and he did
Pomp's podcast if you don't know pomp
here you're not in the crypto world this
guy he was always talking about Bitcoin
so Sam's on tour right now doing a
couple other things they did a meet-up
of listeners and trend subscribers in
New York I saw it it was awesome they're
popping off did you see the feedback
from that I saw the feedback more
important I saw the videos like got some
nice Airbnb like yeah you guys went all
out for this we're spending that was
cool it was really incredible I think
what I loved about the hustle and what
you guys are building here is the
engaged passionate community yes it's
the only way to build something
successful is to be surrounded by people
like yourselves and everyone that was
there was saying hey it's not like you
just go somewhere shake hands share a
business card it's like businesses are
coming off the back end of that right
people are actually starting [__] and
you know I would say - I'll give you two
principles that that these stories tell
me about number one the most important
startup commandment is is you to rather
have a thousand people who love you than
a million people who wanna just kind of
like you you know who could forget about
you if two weeks went by and what I love
about spod cast even though we have
these really aggressive growth goals I
know we already did the hard part that
we have thousands of people who just
love this podcast and that this is my
favorite podcast give me more and I
that's pretty good but take that to your
own business it's easy to be like oh
it's only a hundred it's only a thousand
it's only ten thousand customers right
now but the real question is do they
love you because if they love you you
have a very high chance of getting the
next 10,000 next hundred thousand people
to feel the same way every great brand
that we've seen especially in the DDC
space customer centricity it's at the
heart of what they're doing I don't know
if you saw yesterday Moyes was saying
about at the start 24/7 he was on the
phones in the emails responding today
personally yeah he's an animal it's a
nine hundred million dollar visit and he
brought this up when I did the interview
with him he goes I forgot who we should
mention like whatever the big old spice
like the big deodorant brands Lee was
going up against he goes they don't know
who their customers their customers
target target buys their [__] and puts
it on the chef if they wanted to get in
touch with the people who love their
product they wouldn't even have their
email address they don't have their
connection and he said he realized early
on with
you know he was doing D to C before D to
C was the buzzword it was just called
e-commerce back then and it wasn't super
sexy to be doing but he was doing you
know do deodorant sales and he realized
hey I have this relationship directly
with the customer I could talk to them
they could talk to me I could send them
more products and say hey try this out
is this better I can write them a
thank-you note that sort of thing and I
that was the underrated at the time the
big difference is if you go to Moyes and
you ask him who your customers he's
gonna give you a specific example and if
you go to other competitors they're
gonna show you a slide a demographic
says oh this is Sarah the shopper right
yes the shopper is between the ages of
fifteen and fifty right and then all the
marketing guys are gonna sort of not in
class exactly yeah customer centricity
but you again happy to be here love what
you guys are doing yeah we're gonna get
into a couple ideas
the second principle that I think is
really important so I just bumped into
Stew just doing the podcast and I would
say to two things come from this there's
this phrase proximity is power shout-out
Tony Robbins if you don't know any
better and you want to build your
network you want to be around more
successful people you want to be more
successful yourself one of the best
things you can do is just get near them
like I was just in the office you were
in the office and boom connection made
that's what happened with Mike Brown the
kind of guy who was on the podcast
earlier who does oil and gas in Texas
we're just here we bump into each other
I moved to San Francisco on a lark just
for that I was like I just better go
we're get in the mix I was in Australia
I was as far as you could be from San
Fran you know I was this they're on a
different adventure for the Commonwealth
yeah I'm from Canada so a similar story
if you don't mind me say before what I'm
doing now I helped found this company
called Factory and then let it at the
end and it was literally we were a
handful of guys between Stockholm New
York and Calgary and all we wanted to do
was not just read in books about how
success is made but meet them we wanted
to get where people solving the biggest
challenges in the world and actually
come here so we moved use the Field of
Dreams approach we said if we build it
they will come
win on Craigslist found the biggest
house we could find put our money
together got it shouts out 7-eleven
Scott Street right and legit is the
factory that co-living co-working space
it was anything and everything you could
possibly imagine I've heard so much
about this that's us but all it was was
a network of thought leaders
entrepreneurs executives where we put on
everything from workshops talk
dinner's all we cared about was having
the best people in the world your house
yeah - tell us what is making you
different what is making you tick
how are you building products right
because if you're reading books which is
fantastic I do a lot of it I know you do
you're gonna say hey product is
everything no marketing is everything
customer centricity is everything but
really you have to go there find out for
every industry for every vertical for
every product what makes it different
right and who the entrepreneurs are
actually making it happen yeah and just
get around him like you don't have to
you don't have to figure up step two
just get around it it's the fastest path
to you know sort of improving your odds
of success is get really close literally
proximity you get near by other
successful people work out of their
office hang out with them go to a
co-working space whatever it is get
around successful people even there's a
lot of people in this podcast I imagine
that are probably living in like the
rural states world Canada yeah you know
people like we were cold emailing works
yep
like anyone that cold emails me I
respond I know you guys are the exact
same way even all these executives it's
been really big on Twitter how fast the
response time was it's like if you have
a clear concise message and you either a
want mentorship you want to ask a
question or you want to give them a
piece of feedback they will respond
right and how not to do it is just hey
can I get some of your time hey I'm
Shawn love you get can I have a minutes
or an hour of your time or can I get a
coffee that's the worst way to do it
100% best way to do it is hey I'm Sean
I'm whatever 22 years old I'm from this
place I'm doing this interesting thing
or I really want to do this interesting
thing you I really appreciate the things
you're doing I've shared out your blog
post I've yet told my friends about your
podcast would you take a look at my
slide deck would you play around my
product and give me two bullet points of
what you think I could be doing better
hey I'm gonna be in your city and you
know the next event you guys do I will
organize it for you tell them you're
doing something interesting be humble
about it and and then make it clear and
simple a lightweight ask don't ask for
time don't ask for coffee
how many generic in males are you
getting a week a hundred on a daily
basis this is kind of how I measure the
success of the podcast on a daily basis
I get thirty to forty inbound new
messages
and that's across email LinkedIn and
Twitter DM s LinkedIn I get to like
three months later but like Twitter DM
z-- an email I check every morning it's
just about 30 or 40 unique people doing
that not a huge number but for me that's
like the best part of my day is that
wake up alright who reached out who said
that you know they like something from
this they're doing something interesting
they want to work together I'd invested
now in two companies from the wild
listeners I like in conversations with
several others and so this has been a
big deal for me Wow let's set them apart
so the first guy I think some people
might have heard him on the live show he
was a super credible entrepreneur so he
was like yeah I you know I currently you
know right now I run this division of
the self-driving department at uber and
I'm leaving to start my own self-driving
car company and here's what I'm doing
differently than everybody else
Wow so I was like okay to get to that
position at uber you got to be pretty
legit you have a unique insight that you
can you can tell me very clearly and
then the third thing was like as I
probed the story just got better as I
got to know him I was like wow more
impressed yes as I saw what he had done
more impressed and I was like okay here
you invested yeah okay how long did he
go from email to close so we met we
emailed we met for lunch which is an
hour by the end of the lunch I was like
she'll just go work for this guy like I
was and which is my like ultimate sign
of I should invest and then I went and
checked out their prototype I have got
in the car and that was an hour and then
the last thing I did was I brought my
former co-founder CTO from Bebo who was
with me right now at twitch and I said
hey I need you to assess this from a
technical point of view and so he went
met the guys you know said a bunch of
words that I didn't understand and
walked away being like yeah I'm also
gonna invest and I look great so that's
my due diligence so I would say for
individual hours over the course of
about two weeks wow that's like did you
see first round I think was first round
came out and said that if they look back
10 years ago it took them nine weeks to
close and if they look now it's taking
them nine days yeah if you're an angel
you really need to make decisions within
two meetings you know the first meeting
you need to be able to rule them out if
it's an if it's an oh and if it's a yes
you need to be really clear what that
second meeting needs to be yeah
and then you can do your own research
outside of that to check out the market
talk to a couple of competitors talk to
some customers whatever you need to do
to get comfortable but like speed is
when you don't have pedigree if you
don't have more capital than anyone else
speed is your best asset I agree because
everyone's gonna say that they can help
and a smart entrepreneur knows like hey
you're not gonna help that much yeah and
B everybody says they help so how can I
tell who's actually super helpful until
you have a great track record then
you're like okay this person was a part
of these great successes already I agree
with you fully just to go on that do you
mind if I plug something really quick to
it I'm going to actually I'm gonna plug
the hustle okay so going into talking
about investing how you move forward
what's that first step
did you read the trend support this week
yeah I saw they were like I'm gonna
invent they're gonna invest some money
into startups that it came out of the
community a hundred percent if we think
about you know you talked to Sam a lot
about it over the last four years when
he got the deal flow he heard those
first ideas that were coming out that
are now billion-dollar businesses that
he completely missed or that he could
have helped earlier on and helped them
get to where they are now much earlier
right
it's incredible do you know of any of
those examples that you might not get
Sam's I know a couple of them I don't
know if I should share that's okay but
there's some big ones out there and so I
know these guys have been talking about
it for a while it's like how do we help
the community and like how do we be that
catalyst so now it's not just for trend
subscribers either it's like obviously
shouts out to trends we want you to get
on there and get those nice and ideas
right but for anyone listening I want
you to email Henry act right Henry be at
the hustle Co your best business idea
and if it is chosen we'll give you
$1,000 Henry's $1,000 will also find any
resources that you possibly need to help
this thing scale that's pretty good all
right I like it it's like did you read
atomic habits I've read about a third of
it so far so what really stuck out what
these guys are doing great here and on
what I want kind of every entrepreneur
to hit on is understanding the
difference between motion and action
every lunch brewer thinks they're in
action but legitimately they're talking
about the idea talking about it you with
the idea tweeting about the idea but how
are you taking that forward and so the
big thing here it's like I want to help
you in trends and you want to help them
go from motion to getting into action
and if it's a thousand dollars that it's
gonna be that catalyst that's what makes
sense so what's the difference motion
action okay
talking about it think you're not
actually doing anything but action is
what action is putting up that first
page calling customers actually go
trying to sell them something rapid
prototyping it like putting it into acts
like not blaming anyone else but
legitimately putting it into action to
try to turn this into a real business
right so use this as your excuse
obviously the thousand bucks not gonna
make or break your situation but just
treat it as the catalyst to take the
thing you that's been in the back your
mind and bring it to the forefront take
some action on it I want to see all the
ideas and as the trends community will
all vote on them like it and we're gonna
we're gonna also follow track and show
the community the progression of the
kind of things that are in it cool okay
we got some topics that we wanted to
talk about so what do you start so uh
did you watch the Tyson Fury fight I did
I'm a I'm not a huge boxing fan but I'm
a fan of greatness and I like combat
sports in job there we go I I was lucky
enough I actually watched it with Sam
and Sam is you know big boxing fan and I
think I know a lot of Patriots fans will
say the 28:3 is the greatest comeback
story in sports
I think Tyson Fury is the greatest
comeback so I explained the Tyson Fury
story so just so we can I'm gonna start
at the end okay
Tyson Fury knocked out Deontay Wilder in
the seventh round
Deontay Wilder is known as the baddest
man on the planet right never never been
defeated and he's he has a 96% knockout
rate right 42 fights 41 knockouts
exactly that only person he hasn't
knocked out was his last Tyson Fury
fight
so Tyson Fury started off he's this
English boxer also known as the gypsy
king he was eight weeks premature
weighing in at 1 pound right ok almost
didn't make it just from the beginning
right one pound one pound which is crazy
because if you see him now he's 6 9 6
275 pounds yeah exactly
exactly that in that slim form which
we'll get into but his dad knew
greatness his dad was one of those
people that understood that this guy's
gonna be a champion and so we named him
Tyson after the great Mike Tyson
obviously years go by years go by he
starts training his dad was a boxer his
uncle's a boxers everyone in his family
is boxers and he gets to this point
where he's like the next contender
coming up he's 23 years old he gets
invited into what
Klitschkos actual fighting camp itself
and kind of going back to you guys's
point last week about hearing doubters
everyone always told Tyson Fury you're
gonna go to this camp but wladimir
klitschko is the king right even you're
there he's gonna batter you as a
sparring partner and so he was trying to
go things like this guy's not that great
I'm gonna get into his head these guys
they weren't even boxing against each
other this time not opponents so during
the training camp itself they go into
the sauna okay have you heard this
honest I'm not sore the story now yeah
I'm excited this is maybe my favorite
story in sports so everyone knows and
everyone Telus Ison Fury Vladimir
Klitschko is not just the King of the
Ring
why don't Klitschkos the king of the
sauna okay look everyone here Henry post
a photo of what Vladimir Klitschko looks
like this time he's a monster
yeah he's enormous he's a Russian
monster he's a Russian monster Ukrainian
Russian monster so this guy's huge so
they go into an Tyson Fury's everyone's
telling him you got to get out of town
as fast no one who can last as long as
them and he says I'm not even fighting
this guy I'm gonna get into his head I
want to beat him now because I know I'm
gonna be champion later and people say I
can't do something I'm gonna do it okay
so they get in there it's hot it's
really warming up five minutes go by ten
minutes go by there's about a dozen
people in there people are dropping on
right someone's leave another person's
leavin about 20 minutes come in and it's
only Tyson Fury Atlantic let's go left
so Vladimir Klitschko you know he stands
up Tyson fair he's like thank goodness
he's about to pass out well I don't mean
Klitschko turns up the heat and so Tyson
tree says I can't let this guy get in my
head everyone thinks I can't beat him
I'm gonna get up - he gets something
what he does turns it up grabs the
newspaper lady grabs the newspaper right
another 25 minutes go by then
legitimately as hot as a sauna can go
and Klitschko finally leaves Tyson Perry
wins things like I can't just leave
right now he'll know about I was just
trying to beat him wait a little bit
longer basically passes out years go by
three four years go by Tyson Fury's the
number one contender Chris cause a
champion Klitschkos the champion he
hasn't lost in something like 11 years
11 years hasn't lost right everyone's
like Tyson Fury you cannot beat
Klitschko Tyson Fury goes you know what
I know all of you think I can't do this
I'm gonna do it on
homecourt I don't come to the UK I don't
want to fight you at Wembley I want to
fight you in like Eastern Europe so they
fight in Germany and then so in the pre
fight they do a face to face similar to
how we are now Tyson Fury brings up this
honour issue
Klitschko everyone look up the clip is
so like pretends like it didn't happen
like he couldn't remember it and Tyson
Fury says after the fight he knew that's
when he beat him and he goes in and he
batters right he batters Klitschko wins
right becomes the lineal champion 3 3
class champion whichever by the way I
love this lineal champion the lineal
champion for those who don't fall boxing
is just your you beat the man who beat
the man who beat the man who beat the
man all the way back in time to the
first man exactly and so you have taken
the champion you took the champion out
yes and nobody's taking you out yet
enjoy any old champion he's the lineal
champ so this is 2015 so the thing was
is that after this fight Tyson Fury
didn't go on and actually fight
Klitschko again right he balloons up to
400 pounds he's at the mountaintop he's
like is this it is this it and he's
hearing from everyone he couldn't do it
again he can't do it again
it is finally somewhat getting to him he
becomes addicted to drugs he gets
addicted to booze he's 400 pounds and
everyone says I knew it I knew Tyson
Fury was a bum right right and so
finally something in his mind clicks
2017 this video comes out him jogging
his face is monstrous size of a bass
he's ready he looks like someone who ate
Tyson Fury exactly and he there's this
video everyone's gotta see it and he
said he says it's like Gionta Wilder I'm
coming for you and everyone says he's
never talked about he's failed so many
times he'll never come back
yeah and little obviously he fights some
he comes back he drops a hundred and
fifty pounds it was a draw the first
fight time comes back they're like you
know what Tyson Fury is he's not coming
back he's gonna do the WWE thing he got
his payday he's gonna go drink again
comes back obviously this past Saturday
knocks out actually knocks out the
nachus
knockout artist a hundred percent no one
thought he could do it right and so I
just thought it was this really
interesting story for a lot of the
points that even we were talking about
last week or you guys were talking about
last week when it came down to people
saying no right people not wanting to
see success happen
everyone wants to see you blues and he
took that as energy came back like four
separate times that's right from the
brink like four separate times and made
it happen I just thought it was just
some I can tell you're kind of like me
in that maybe the thing I respect most
is someone's mentality yes their mental
toughness and and I don't I don't even
think I'm particularly great at this but
it's something that I've decided is sort
of the number one most important asset
is how how is your mindset 104,000
mindset where things are good are you
grateful are you appreciative are you a
giver to others yeah how is your mindset
when things are bad yes are you
resilient do you do you turn the
disadvantages into advantages and
mindset is number one that's why you
love fury yes doesn't matter that he
knocked a guy it matters how his mind
worked he was at a point where most
people break Angela Duckworth would call
it grit right what this guy has right
like when I read that book all I could
think about was Tyson Fury but it all
comes down to mindset all the great
leaders have it Admiral William McRaven
is another great example obviously one
of the greatest Admirals and Navy SEALs
history on special ops history same
thing he's a great leader because of how
his mindset is right this is why sports
is grapes the metaphor it's the grand
metaphor for life uh-huh who cares about
these guys punching each other in the
head or throwing a ball in a hoop but it
is the great many real post a bunch of
the things that we talked about I want
everyone to go to the hustle and my
first million everyone on Twitter and I
want you to all look at these links and
be inspired yes I love it and there's a
great fight it was very dirty and he
gave us a nice little ballad Oh Mike he
sings a song when he lands which is
hilarious and part of like his
marketability is that he's just like
crazy character he was dancing before
the fight yeah well there was stress you
can he was literally dancing by the way
super lame excuse by Deontay Wilder that
his costume was too heavy and that's why
he lost no you lost coaster yeah very
punch in the head yeah all right so what
else we got so let's do a couple of the
ideas so let's go down we're gonna skip
this one let's do a couple of the ideas
that that we were chatting about last
time so if you were here for the sports
you got what you wanted if you were here
for the ideas this is the time okay so
what are some of the ideas that are
interesting to you well last week when I
was sitting in you guys mentioned that
religion overall is declining
and I didn't think that was right and so
I looked at the numbers and actually
there's 66 million people coming and I'm
just gonna speak towards Christianity
sure 66 million new Christians every
single year right people being born into
it people are converting and so on with
only 26 million people leaving the
church which means 40 million euro net
net net positive 3.3 billion by 2050
right which is pretty incredible and I
don't know on Instagram if anyone that's
listening to the podcast follows but
there's a lot of actual Christian
entrepreneurs yes and Christian
influencers so you have people like Karl
Lance rich Wilkerson jr. vous Church
even and let me ask are you a religious
guy or are you interested in this from a
just a curiosity and business point of
view both okay so I like I'm part of a
men's group like a men's Christian group
and it's interesting and like kind of
diving into the idea itself a lot of my
friends have kids that are growing up
every single way that the church
traditionally engages with this younger
this younger demographic is outdated
right read the Bible read the Bible you
know listen to me talk but sit down and
listen exactly there it there's no way
right now there's no media company
coming out there's there's really
nothing out there for new age consumers
Gen Z's Millennials to actually engage
with the church right so we're thinking
this is not like this is an area where
there's 40 million people every single
year joining that's a pretty fantastic
growth right billions of built-in
customers and by 2050 obviously they're
getting born right now for the most part
or they're people like us it's like how
are they going to engage with the church
itself there's there's only a handful of
companies that are somewhat looking into
this but if we look at even the way that
culture is trending look at Kanye West
last album yeah legitimately a gospel
album look at some of the brands that
are really taking off right now fear of
God Jerry Lorenzo right a Christian
backed fashion company right but there's
only a handful of them the opportunity
is massive to create either a media
company or you know you could be selling
books you could whatever it might be to
engage with those younger consumers so I
got a couple ideas so someone in someone
from the community like you said
somebody who'd taken action he messaged
me he said give me three months mm-hmm
so give me three months what three
months
sent me a link and he and and not you
know I hope he's okay with me sharing
this Alaska me afterwards we could bleep
this whole thing otherwise but he said
give me three months and I'm gonna show
you that I can get this business off the
ground I'm gonna get on your show Wow
and he goes what is that what's the
business he goes tithing Wow so he goes
digital tithing so basically let's give
it a 10 LG venmo for churches so he goes
there's this company called push pay
that is currently processing four
billion dollars a year of digital
donations inside a church so instead of
passing the hat around
they passed I don't know the QR code
around or whatever it is it's like you
can donate to the church through through
it out and Ty Lee is another one so push
pay 4.2 billion that's they're processed
amount they took 98 million Wow
so this is a very simple FinTech company
to build distribution you can tell how
you would distribute it to customers
through the churches themselves we have
a high incentive because you know if
your church you need to ask for money
and then you grow or you don't ask for
money and then you shrink and
potentially close and if we think what
this former church's perspective as well
it'll help them with all their
accounting right every week every Sunday
Saturday whenever going to church
they're accepting cash right someone has
to sit down and like sit down you know
is this tithing money is this for
something else so just the accounting of
it imagine how much more that'll be they
said fifteen percent I was looking into
a little bit fifteen percent of all
donations now and the churches is
digital but I bet that that's so I bet
that that's already you know you know
fivefold increase from where it was a
few years ago
and I bet it's gonna go further I think
it gets to thirty forty percent over
time and and so this is just churches
and you know just one faith so there's a
you can copy an existing model take it
to another faith you could just compete
against these so let's say tithing is
one let's say you know surface area
where you might go for what's another
well just going on that that one point
right there what is really interesting
is did you see bird come out with
payments this week yes do you think bird
is gonna get it they're gonna have bird
payments yeah at the front of all
exactly about I don't I don't think I
think bird is in the sort of last-minute
Hail Mary type thing yeah okay okay well
interesting what is another one the
biggest one to me just comes down to
engagement right you all
have a passionate community of young
people that want to be engaged with the
church what we've seen a lot of is
merchandise right so how can you
physically show that you were engaged
with the Christian or Catholic or
whatever your church actually is right
so influencer marketing obviously being
big preacher sneakers is a really
interesting instagrams that happening
it's big preacher snake preachers well
picture sneakers shows what all the
preachers globally are actually wearing
right now so it's like how can you
create a brand directly for them
themselves and that's a perfect bridge
of like the faith and I know Gen Z yeah
you know cross over there so that really
gets me excited yeah so I like the media
business idea I think that's a pretty
straightforward one although probably
not the most lucrative we had talked a
little bit about beautiful Bibles or
beautiful Bibles to talk about this I
like this idea a lot well I'm just you
think to yourself it's you if you have
if you were a Christian or whatever your
religion might be but let's just say for
Christianity sake you go to someone's
house I guarantee you their Bible has
hidden away because it got passed down
to them they got it for oral it's it's
hideous but if you think of what is on
I shouldn't say hideous but it's not the
best looking book it's okay
but if I think what is on people's
coffee tables right now it's kinfolk
right it's things that are going that
they're buying that are beautifully
bound that they're visual and so I think
there's this really great opportunity to
reinvent what the Bible actually looks
like and create like the kinfolk of
Bibles yes so number one most selling
book of all time yes the Bible that's a
good place to start VIP again you can
print your own Bible so it's not like
you're gonna go a reprint Fifty Shades
of Grey and get sued yeah you can go Bri
print this and it could work
you can remix it so you can simplify you
can distill you can pull out certain
anecdotes I love this idea so the only
reason I'm not doing this idea is cuz
I'm not really just uh-huh but even me
I'm just like would you listen
no it's like I love how you just said
pull out specific books yeah so Netflix
didn't really a pretty interesting movie
on the book of Mark
right and so like how can you take some
of the stories that were within there
and actually have them come to
double-click into that yeah I like that
a lot so so I think this generally
speaking taking the sort of number one
most best-selling book of all time or if
you look at the Gita or the Koran or
whatever these are all in the top
sellers of all time and if you can you
know put a remix on it so aesthetically
pleasing is where I would go with it
first the other side of it is you know
distilling it down for kids making it
more kid-friendly or like you said going
into sort of some of the lesser told or
pulling out some of the anecdotes and
stories and really bringing them to life
14 million new customers a year right do
it as a youtube channel do it as a book
I think these are I think this is really
interesting if someone's doing this
reach out to me I want to help you make
this successful I put a lot of thought
into to how you would go about doing
this and I genuinely think it's really
really really fascinating idea and this
influencer preacher thing what's up with
that it's so it's funny I thought a lot
about it and guys in my men's group and
I think it's a really great way to bring
kind of the youth back into like
Christianity for instance but they have
millions of followers you know they're
with Bieber all the time parlance is the
first one I saw that was doing this I
launched the biggest you got to think he
was leading Hillsong right and if you
dressed a little differently you could
pass it Karl and that might be that
might be my next movie we'll see if they
reach I saw him and I was like skies
looking this act fellow stylish fan
funny fantastic speech speaks in like
comments you know common tongue not like
you know he'll use slang yeah and I was
like no wonder this guy's friends with
all the basketball players and you know
musicians that everybody knows about he
reformed Bieber 100% know it's really
interesting and he's speaking to them on
their level that is really the biggest
thing and so people understand that this
is like being I want to be a strong
Christian let's say and I want it to be
aspirational yet attainable I can be him
right instead of like the typical
preacher you'll see it a lot of the
churches it's like you could look up to
someone like Carl Lentz mean like that
is someone I want to aspire to be right
and there's also sort of a musical
component so he's with the Hillsong
Church I think and they put out like
tons of great you know faith-based music
I think that faith-based music is it was
a pretty big space so here's a question
I had about us right because I've
rain storm these I broke some of them
down have done a bit of research and so
then I asked for some I believe in these
ideas man okay but I'm not doing I'm not
doing these ideas yep a big part of it
for me is just time I got a lot I do the
podcast every job I have you know other
stuff going on so for someone like you
entrepreneurial Christian why don't you
do this idea I'm one of these well I'm
in the same place as you I'm also dry
limited it's all time limited I will do
anything to help these get off the
ground any of the ideas we'll talk about
right it's like you want to see people
take these really nice and interesting
ideas that are big and help them come to
life and so if I had more time on my
hands I would love to help it and where
do you stand on where do you stand on
ideas where you don't have that same
founder fit so let's take another so
let's say I did have the time okay right
I magically get 48 hours of my day so I
can play with my baby I can do my job I
can invest in companies I could do the
podcast home I can do the side all cells
I could do it all so let's say I had
double the time and now I could now I'm
not time restricted you know the second
question for you should I do this and is
this the right business for me because
there's one thing to understand that at
an intellectual level there's other
things to really like love the product
care about it and get into all those
details so I think a lot of people come
into this question of like yes should I
go for something I'm quote-unquote
passionate about or know about or I am
the customer or should I do something
that's sort of I see the opportunity it
might be a great market opportunity but
I have to figure out you know it's like
our buddy Ramon who you know created the
most popular soap opera soap opera blog
in the world and never watch the so
proper in his life and sold it for 9
million cash so I've seen both examples
yeah where do you stand on this my whole
thing I think I think entrepreneurs have
to be at different stages in their life
so for we're wrong Ramon was that he's
not saying soap opera blog this is the
hundred year brand this is something
that when people say what did Ramon do
to leave this earth he changed the lives
of people watching soap operas right he
said how can I
especially where he was at in his life
how can I make money right and he says
this is something that could generate
money tomorrow
yeah and so now when you're talking
about things that are really passionate
that that you really care about where
you like when you were building bebo
when time slips away when you have that
feeling you care so much about what
you're building that you look at the
clock and it's 4:00 a.m.
you're with your co-founders and you
said wow we're really changing the world
it's a whole different place there
you're trying to build a brand not just
a flip but to literally make an impact
right like so I think you have to look
at yourself where you're at in your life
can you take risks like you're saying I
know you you've been successful so you
have kids you have a family but it's
like can I take this risk do I have the
right time and do I care about this
because it's if I just want to make
money right now become an affiliate
marketer right something like take one
of these ideas that you could just
easily flip around start making money
tomorrow or do I want to build something
long-term that is probably much higher
risk but it's something that I want to
really put my name to right so the
framework I offer up here is earn learn
or legacy which one are you going for
right now and at different phases of my
life you summed it up oh my god I've
optimized for different ones when I
moved to San Francisco I told you I just
wanted to be near people yeah I decided
at that time I had done two startups
already I said next one I don't want to
do myself because you know I've made
these two startups happen with mixed
results you know some good some bad I
think I've done better than I thought I
would do but I don't know what I don't
know so I was like this next chapter is
all about learning so I hooked up with
Michael birch I was like this guy's done
it before he's a billionaire he's built
multiple successful companies great head
of hair great head of hair British
accent yeah can't go wrong and I said I
want to learn so I said I don't want to
just how can I my feces how do I pack 20
years of experience into the next four
years of my life I love that and so I
said I got to work with someone who's
done it before I gotta be around really
smart people and I got to work on a
portfolio of projects so I get multiple
reps and not just one yeah and then I
found Michael Byrd she was dead before
and an ideal abbyr he's working on a
portfolio I've started ideas boom
perfect laughs so I went all-in I was
like this is what I want
other times right now I'm in the urn
face sold my company I'm trying to
collect the check of America cash in the
asset that we sold and collect the check
yeah of course I'm gonna still learn
things but I've picked you know there
are other ways I could be learning more
I decided this chapter right now I'm
gonna cash in some chips I'm gonna earn
and if we look at your earn as well
going back to the first question it's
you have a portfolio of bets you have
you've made your money from selling your
company you get paid I'd assume on the
1st and 15th from twitch or however the
payment works and you've also made
higher risk longer-term bets itself that
could have a high payout at the
right right and so you have multiple
different streams of income that could
be coming in that are gonna help you
achieve the long term goals of the type
of earning potential that you want to be
hitting right and so if you're listening
and the other one it's legacy and I've
thought about this okay what would I do
next would i optimize again for learning
sometimes I'll just do a little
experiment that I know I'm not gonna
stick with beyond three months yeah but
I'm like how hard is it to start a
podcast yeah do could I grow that that's
how this started as an experiment to
just learn I didn't think I'd earn any
money off this I didn't think it's good
for legacy necessarily I just did it to
learn and sometimes you know think about
what's a project I wouldn't want to exit
from yep it's a powerful question to
answer but it's a powerful question Wow
I absolutely love that that's incredible
and you know it kind of what you're
saying with that urn learn legacy a lot
of the work that I currently do is with
corporate still so I work with both like
growth States Jarvis but mostly with
corporates and when I help them kind of
look at what is the future of the
business look like we actually go
through a very similar lens it's like
how are we gonna make the next billion
rights like what does a horizon 2
project look like right then what is the
future of our business actually look
like and who are the types of people
that we want to be surrounding ourselves
with network startups investors whomever
it might be they're gonna help us
understand what that is but not just
help us understand and get those
insights but help us build that like
that's a lot of the work that I do right
now that's cool I like that let's talk
about this other idea that you had
mentioned last time so uber driver
revenue streams total revenue streams
and lyft you know I don't discriminate
yeah no I love them both right
whatever's cheaper but for me I try to
think a lot about there are resting
assets that are currently sitting idle
right and so how can you what's a
resting asset a resting asset is
something like how uber a scale because
they have drivers that are sitting out
there for themselves or people just
driving around that want to make extra
income so for uber for instance how can
we take that a step further you have
people that are online with uber that
are currently waiting for rides and they
have when they get someone in their car
they have a captive audience there's
been a handful of startups that if
somewhat helped alleviate this because
the big thing that has come out a lot
lately especially with some of the new
regulations coming in is that uber and
lyft drivers driving full-time are
making far less than minimum wage right
like far less when you account for all
the expenses and the idle time
I think we have the stat here what does
it say the average pay per hour in
America for full time is 855 to 1177 on
uber on uber yeah
or all right yeah right yeah in America
the average full time for a driver
full-year 36 525 a year right that's
that's that's minimum wage right and so
I think it's no one they're not gonna
stop driving they're not gonna stop
driving left but how can you take
something like a uber or lyft driver who
for between seven and thirty minutes has
a captive audience right so how do you
give them a three dollar an hour raise
how do you help them make more money so
people have tried this currently
interactive media I think we there's a
octopus interactive has done this
everyone's seen it it's in all cabs in
New York it's in a handful of uber
screen on the back a little tech thing
you play a game yeah it's not targeted
so you and me are getting in there and I
guarantee you if we set in there right
now we're gonna get served
personal injury call me if you've been
hurt in an accident
right has nothing to do with us okay but
that's one way one way another one that
I actually liked was cargo and it just
helps them sell things right
snack little snack bar exactly but to me
what I've been thinking a lot about is
how do you which is really big obviously
the last handful of years which has
really taken off is personalization so
if you think about if you're able to
truly partner with uber think about the
type of information they have when you
as a rider how old you are
your frequent places that you're living
even the micro targeting the geolocation
of where you are we can make a lot of
assumptions about you we could you know
Xiaomi could probably assume you're
you're well-off maybe we can know that
you have family or you're currently
doing a lot of pools or luxury and so we
can start to build a profile around you
and with that type of information
through like the stereo for instance how
could we serve you very targeted direct
ads right so advertising is one the one
that I am really interested in I have a
little bit of background in is in the
music space and so for me it's like okay
a music label wants to get their new
artist someone that they've invested in
in front of the right consumer
especially in that first week where they
want songs to hit that kind of viral
effect right and so if you were able to
build a music platform to partner with
labels and over to actually serve direct
music towards a very targeted audience
and you could make money by playing that
song right I think it'd be a great
business yeah that's pretty interesting
cuz I don't know how many rides there
are per day but there's millions of
rides per day and so those are all sort
of audio impressions yeah you could use
and if I think if you played ads out
loud that would be sort of obnoxious but
if you're playing awesome new music you
know that could be that could be really
interesting where it's sort of
non-invasive it's actually you know sort
of behind the scenes yeah you don't even
have to tell the rider hey this is you
know you're listening to this because of
X it's just there's what the driver has
on ya and the driver gets paid to have
their radio on exactly specifically to a
certain station a lot looked into their
app cuz a lot of the time either you're
telling them what to change too or
they're putting on something you don't
like right and so now this is okay we
think we understand you as an individual
so we're gonna try to serve you music
that you like right and I'm helping the
driver make more money right yeah I like
this idea a lot I think this is cool
Firefly put the big kind of thing on the
top of the the Ebers is that is it
Firefly that raised last week or was it
the other one so Firefly raised prior
and it may have raised again I don't
know they raised a huge round prior and
like 20 30 million bucks and then I
believe lyft announced that they were
doing this themselves
so one of the ride-sharing companies
announced what they're doing this
themselves which is gonna be now
interesting to see what happens with
that but I like the idea I also just
generally like the underlying reason
this was interesting to you which was
something's changed so what's changed
okay well now we have this fleet of
drivers that are all connected using
these apps that are on the road all the
time that's new inventory and we could
do something with new opportunity that
we could do something with and the
second thing was hey the wages have gone
down from making $25 an hour to $10 an
hour they're gonna be very receptive to
ways that they can get their earnings
back up because they're being advertised
to that hey you're making 25 bucks an
hour yeah but that's not your true rate
when you take into account everything
and if you find a way to make the
drivers more money even I I bet you I'm
just gonna make an assumption here that
if uber doesn't get a cut but they're
keeping more drivers on the road that
they will leave you alone yeah they will
love you if I find any way to make
drivers work exclusively like I think
cargo is an exclusive partnership with
uber right and so if you can help just
them like they're there
driver retention yeah I I think could
really take off yeah I like that idea
what else you got you had some other
good ones last time so we touched on
sort of how religion should be engaging
with Gen Z whether it's under the
beautiful Bibles or tithing or one of
the other ideas they're living what are
we gonna call this super driver radio
network you know we need a higher a
brand or from our name I have one name
it is coming up for our next idea that
I've come up with okay yeah but besides
that all right so you can give us that
and give us that name well you should
see a lot of the domains that I own
there it's just awful awful awful
domains I should never be in branding
but so the next idea that that I have
that we kind of talked about I'm
actually talking about it with one of my
friends right now so anyone that wants
to join this next idea email Henry be at
the hustle dot go and you'll help
connect us ed are you getting blown up
today I'm excited to see how many he
gets charged your phone so I'm really
big into cloud kitchens you give a great
summary of what cloud kitchen says do
you mind yeah yeah sure okay so cloud
kitchens I actually know this because I
started one way back before this is a
thing oh right idea wrong time but
basically it is a restaurant without the
physical restaurant so you now that
there's all these delivery apps Buber
eats post mates caviar or - or - GrubHub
you just your storefront is a icon in
the app that's all you need you and so
there's all these shared kitchens like
just giant warehouses think about it
that way that are centrally located in
the city but not super sexy locations
and there's these giant kitchens that
I've already invested in all the HVAC
fryers fridges freezers you don't have
to buy any of that stuff you can go rent
those by the hour when we did it we paid
19 bucks an hour Wow to have access to
this kitchen
and so like think about that you know
eight eight times you know 20 20 bucks
an hour times eight hours a day that was
our restaurant cost so we went from
needing half a million dollars to start
our restaurant to doing it for like less
than 5 that 5 grand and we you know so
you have this infrastructure that's a
shared kitchen where normally Baker's
caterers food truck guys that's what
they normally use but now you could just
run a whole restaurant out of that you
just optimize delivery only and you live
on the back of these giant of
food apps and you just do pop-up
concepts so you could be macaroni only
you could be you know the fried chicken
specialist the grilled cheese specialist
you could be like ten different types of
Asian cuisine are like the best pad thai
ever whatever you create these little
micro brands anyways a cloud kitchen is
a kitchen as a restaurant that doesn't
exist and delivers off the back of these
super popular food delivery apps and so
what you just said and you said how many
platforms there are the number one
question because whenever you look at
starting a new problem or you starting a
new startup sorry you look at is there a
challenge here or is there a big
opportunity and so with this one I took
I looked at myself and I said what is
the biggest challenge that these cloud
kitchens face you see how much money
Travis clinics obviously started I bet
you he walked down the street and
someone else has probably started one
yeah and I guarantee you the biggest
problem everyone has is how do you stand
out how do you stand out as a cloud
kitchen because you don't have a
storefront so are you gonna put a lot of
money into brand right is are you gonna
stand out just on your logo or that your
key dough and you do nice foods so
something that I've been thinking a lot
about which I'm calling are you ready
for it
clout kitchens is influencer based cloud
kitchens okay and so if you look at the
expansion of influencer marketing and
not just influencers as a pay to play
scheme that startups are or large
corporates are working with to hawk
their products but instead actually
having these influencers build real
businesses look at Kylie yep
Kylie didn't sit there and build out the
formulations herself she put a ton of
work into it and like a hundred percent
that is incredible what she did but she
worked with a brand incubator who on the
back end knew the formulations they knew
how to market it they knew everything
behind it and leveraged her distribution
her name to make it scale the way they
did same thing with Rihanna did it so
what's happening in the beauty space
what you're saying is could happen in
the food space so who's a how would this
work give me an example I'm just so in
my mind it's someone you can do
influence there's a handful of different
ways if you go onto Instagram right now
how many different food influencers are
there thousands thousands Jo WIC Ella
delicious you know all these different
ones that like my partner for instance
she we own every cookbook I feel
yeah we own legitimate ly every could my
wife's vegan so any vegan influencer
like I know I know the name Aaron
Ireland she's she sends me every recipe
that this almond post which is a you
know baking recipe a hundred percent I
go on Instagram right now I guarantee
you I have four messages from her from
different food things that we should try
right and it will say I eat out too much
so instead of going in figuring out okay
how do I build this recipe oh gosh I got
a bike I got to make couscous I don't
even know what it is instead it's like
how can you leverage the name of this
influencer help them with some of the
recipes that they have on their
Instagram itself create the menu create
the menu and create all these cloud
kitchens like across the country or
wherever it might be so that everyone
can have access to it I like it I like
it a lot so this is sort of like the
Gordon Ramsay he has several restaurants
right like he's got his Bobby Flay has
the burger bar Gordon Ramsay has his
thing in Vegas and other places I feel
like every somewhat decent Airport has a
go Wolfgang Puck right and so or you
guys talked about it with Lance Jimmy
Buffett we're going to Margaritaville
you're somewhere warm and so what is the
Margaritaville what is the Gordon Ramsay
what is that next generation working
with these New Age influencers to
actually create full menus online just
in a cloud kitchen with none of the
upfront costs and as you know how high
the churn rate is on restaurants itself
yeah your start-up costs are incredibly
low all you need to do is find the right
influencer the right demographic build
out the menu with them write of things
they're already building they have
you're just giving access to everywhere
then you grab off the shelf chefs
essentially who can actually just
implement and 100 cook the food on a
daily basis right yeah trivial to find
people who could do that I really like
this idea because I just think it's a
really fun idea and there's a lot of
times where you have passion actually
the music wants very similar there's all
these passion areas that are just
garbage businesses yes and this is you
know food is another one where it's like
great you love food okay what are you
gonna do you're gonna be a foodie what
does that mean you're gonna be a food
blogger that's a little bit tough this
is actually like a sort of cool novel
way and again it's because something has
changed yes these food delivery apps
have have paid billions of dollars in
customer acquisition costs yes to
acquire hundreds of millions of users
across the world you don't have to get
you like you don't have to pay for the
yeah you're not paying for the customers
they're coming to you yes exactly so I
like this a lot and I think you sort of
can bridge these two these two worlds
really really well so I like to say that
my friend has this phrase which is that
chefs are the new DJs yes that people
just the same way people follow DJs now
and will go to the clubs where they're
at
there's this is actually happening in
sort of the food world look at what's
what's that chef or what's that show on
Netflix open to not open table chef's
table chef's table like that
Oh like that just took off right and so
on yeah I I'm 100% with you the one
thing I want to add is I want someone to
do this yeah I don't just want us to
talk about this anyone that is
interested I want them to email Henry
I'm not even joking we're starting this
I have someone on the other end that is
gonna help with this I'll help it get
off the ground right motion to action I
love it and again literally we did this
when we did our restaurant we so we
started a sushi restaurant yeah I don't
know [__] about sushi yeah I like that
at Duke right I did that right out of
Duke and we found a chef from the Food
Network so we saw this guy who did the
Bobby Flay challenge he beat Bobby Flay
at a sushi challenge and he was super
charismatic and he was obviously knew
his [__] about sushi and so we were like
oh that guy we need that guy huh and so
we literally partnered with this guy it
was really hard to get him to take us
seriously because we're 18 years old and
there's a whole story about how we did
that but we're part of the Food Network
Chef and we created this this restaurant
concept and then we ended up because we
just didn't have money we did it as a
cloud kitchen yeah because we were like
look I don't want to sign a 10-year
lease with a personal guarantee and
that's what I needed to do to get a
restaurant space so you know just
getting resourceful we created this
thing and at the time there was no post
mates ubereats those didn't exist that
was the missing piece we still had to go
get customers to come to our website to
download to order the food is this if
that had changed this whole you know I
wouldn't even be sitting here I'd be so
running a sushi bar is this gonna be
your legacy I feel like we just hit on
something I feel like this is next now I
ran away from the food industry because
it's tough but that's just I was doing
too much too many dishes every night
that's incredible I love that anyone
that wants to do it honestly Henry be at
the hustle ko
I love it all right so we got a little
bit time let's see how we're doing on
time okay we don't have too much time
all right we have let's say one last
thing is there one last thing you want
bring up this is Stu's power our without
the power our I have so many ideas
hopefully you have me back I fully
understand I feel like I yell into this
mic as much as Sam so I'm gonna
apologize everyone listening well we
want to bring you back we want to have
basically these recurring sort of
friends of the house so there's certain
people that are fun and have a bunch of
ideas and it's not like when I was doing
the interviews before you know you tell
your story once I'm not gonna have you
back to tell your story again like
that's just too much nobody wants that
but with this you know every month or
every two months I want to be brain you
know our guest friends of the house back
as a recurring cast a character so
that's the pregame plan
count me in you can catch me at my desk
about 15 feet from there but something
that I've been thinking about a lot
you're a big notion user right I use it
I wouldn't call this a big notion user
because I have a love/hate with it okay
uh-uh app load so slow for me it does
load low that's like a deal-breaker for
me but everything else to don't but you
guys made the website we made our whole
website off of it honestly it's one of
the most powerful tools I've ever used
the hard thing is I tell everyone and
everyone knows I'm an evangelist of
things that I love I must have signed up
200 people on copper for instance I'm
calling people everyone's like what CRM
do I use I'm done with and like now you
get on copper right now I've been taking
any affiliate money for this by the way
right
and so notion is the latest thing I'm
addicted my life journals in there
everything my whole life is it what do
you love about notion that you didn't
get it what were using before Docs
Evernote you name it I was using the
whole G suite I was using obviously
copper but I've actually poured it over
a CRM into it cuz there's a lot of
really great integrations I'm using a
physical journal itself like you name a
sauna and what what is it about notion
that got you what got it was the ability
to create it's legitimately a blank
canvas where let's you be the artist
towards your own personal workspace deep
there if people that are watching this
I'm crying
yeah watching us so but legitimately the
hard thing though what makes it so
beautiful and what makes it so difficult
is that you legitimately just end up on
a blank page create fright and so I
think the biggest opportunity notion has
to
of them so many times and I will
continue to is that they have the
opportunity to legitimately create the
App Store for business templates and so
if you go on notion dot SL for it slash
templates they have a couple they've
about twelve but if you want to become a
power user you got to go on YouTube you
got to find all the right channel right
and so I think there's a really big
opportunity for someone or for notion
itself to become an actual template or
sorry a an actual platform in an app
store to create templates for notion
right ready to go
CRM ready to go ready to go whatever all
the different common use cases at 100% I
think it's something massive opportunity
like they've raised what 10 million at
an 800 million valuation and they have
such an engaged community but nothing is
tying them together right like people
are hacking together templates I use it
but it looks low ok you know so much
information yeah that's probably what it
is it's like so feature-rich said
Melissa alright I like that notion you
should pay us for that I mean they
accept that so they that wasn't an ad
read but that was better than an ad read
yeah they did they actually sponsored
the hustle morning newsletter today
right yeah me and you didn't give me
that much let's get out here all right
do great Avenue where should people find
you follow you twitter twitter at Stu
Iverson follow me on there I put it in
the show nos yeah I'm active DM me I'll
message you back I promise you
yeah that's we can find me nice okay
love it we're out